Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Wo sind wir hier?
Wir sind im Saalbau in Bornheim in Frankfurt.
Hinter uns sind wir.
Und gleich beginnt die große Live-Show. Ich habe schon gehört, du hast dir Sommerinterviews angesehen.
Alle.
Aber ein bisschen anders, nämlich wie junge Menschen das machen als Twitch-Stream.
Die Tagesschau macht ein Tagesschau-together-Format. Dort wird das 30 Minuten Sommerinterview in drei Stunden gestreamt. Das heißt, da ist sehr viel Zeit Blödsinn zu labern. Und junge Leute zu indoktrinieren, falls du es noch nicht wusstest. Von Birgensdörr ganz böse, schlagähnig, wurde aussortiert, historisch überholt und so. Wir überprüfen nachher die Argumentation.
Ich habe Clips dabei, vor allem von Taylor Lawrence. Sie setzt sich ja sehr stark für Free Speech ein. Und ich muss auch sagen, je mehr ich über all das nachdenke, desto mehr komme ich auch zu dem Schluss, ich bin für absolute Free Speech. Jetzt sind wir ja bekanntlich welche, die auch immer gewarnt haben, vor Folgen soziale Medien und so weiter. Stichwort Manfred Spitzer oder manche Thesen von Jonathan Hyde fanden wir auch gar nicht so schlecht. Ich bin gespannt, wie du dich gleich dazu in Stellung bringen wirst. Ich habe den Eindruck, du wirst widersprechen. Aber ich glaube, es geht nicht ohne Free Speech. Und wir dürfen, um das Bild einmal zu gebrauchen, das Kind nicht mit dem Bade ausgießen. Und das geschieht gerade.
Freespeech ist nur in Amerika, Artikel 1. Und auch dort nicht der einzige. Ich werde nachher ein bisschen dagegenhalten.
Okay, also wir diskutieren über Freespeech und wir beantworten Fragen aus dem Publikum, die jetzt gleich bei uns eintreffen werden.
Wären wir uns eigentlich auf Bierdecken zugeworfen?
Ich denke, wir sammeln sie in Ruhe ein und dann werden wir uns diesen Fragen stellen. Das jedenfalls gibt es dann alles im Live-Salon, nachzuhören und zu sehen. Und wir haben auch noch eine Ankündigungsmache, die Bücher, die wir als nächstes lesen. Wir wollen uns mit dem Thema Polarisierung beschäftigen. Und da erscheinen zwei Bücher, geradezu gleichzeitig. Also schon erschienen ist das Buch Polarisierung von Nils Kumka bei Suhrkamp. Der sagt offenbar, ich habe das Buch noch nicht gelesen, Polarisierung ist eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht. Man muss sie nur besser gestalten. Wir sind gespannt, was er damit meint. Und es gibt noch ein zweites Buch zur Polarisierung, das jetzt Anfang September erscheint, nämlich Verbinden statt Spalten heißt das.
Vom Bundespräsidenten?
Nein, eben von Gilda Sahibi. Und das hat mich ein bisschen überrascht, dieser Titel, da ich sie gar nicht so als die gesehen habe, die vereinen will. Aber wahrscheinlich wird sie das auf eine Art tun, die uns doch überrascht. Wir werden jedenfalls uns diese beiden Konzepte oder Theorien zur Polarisierung ansehen, denn das ist ja definitiv so. Wir leben in polarisierten Zeiten.
Ja, ich will auch, dass es mehr polarisiert ist. Ich weiß nicht genau, was die Leute da haben.
Okay, dann müssen wir gleich bei Freespeech richtig aufeinander losgehen. Wir werden sehen. Jetzt erst mal einen schönen Abend, beziehungsweise wer das dann nachhört. Viel Vergnügen damit. Wir sollten aber noch ganz kurz sagen, wie man jetzt diesen Live-Sanon nachhören kann.
Man geht auf 29er.de. Wir sind ein Podcast mit eigener Webseite. Mick hat keine eigene Webseite. Der sitzt hier am Bühnenrand und kriegt gleich von mir wieder einen Einlauf. Also jeder gute Podcast hat eine eigene Webseite, weil da kann man goldene Button unterbringen. Das haben wir gemacht. Das ist der Salon. Da kommt man dahin. Wir präferieren wie immer Steady. Man kann den Salon aber auch bei Apple Podcastion oder bei Patreon, wenn man da die Accounts schon hat oder es einem einfacher fällt. Aber bei Steady bekommt man das ganze Archiv, alle Kapitelmarken, der eigene RSS Feed. Gut, den kriegt man in One, das sind auch aktuelle Coverbilder und so weiter und so fort.
Und wir würden uns freuen, wenn ihr ein Jahresabo abschließt, denn das ist nicht nur etwas günstiger für euch, sondern auch für uns etwas günstiger, weil dann die diversen Zahlungsdienstleister, und in die Hälfte dieser ist, glaube ich, Sam Altmann inzwischen investiert, dann ein bisschen weniger Geld bekommen, weil die Zahlung ja nur einmal jährlich erfolgt.
So ist es.
Jetzt viel Vergnügen mit dem Live Salon.